[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
and host of the Ken Coleman show where
he talks about career and jobs all day
long he's my co-host today we're going
to be talking to you about your life
right in front of you the phone number
is
88255 225 the call is free and some say
the advice is worth exactly what you pay
for it Ben starts this hour in Cheyenne
Wyoming hi Ben welcome to the ramsy
show hi Dave and Ken so grateful to be
on the show today thank you again for uh
taking my call sure what's up in your
wh well um the brief synopsis of the
situation is I'm wondering if I should
take on an additional student loan um to
go through a coding boot camp um to in
essence double my uh income so that I
can uh accelerate my baby step two
progress uh for my
family okay so um I'm guessing you've
not been listening to us for very long
um it's been off and on for a couple of
months um I know the short answer would
be of course not don't be stupid um
that's a good short
answer yes sir how much how much is the
boot camp gonna
cost so the boot camp is um
$13,900 and what is your expected
increase in income from what now to what
then what would you be making
um currently I'm making um $38,000 a
year and I would be bring bringing that
up to anywhere between 75,000 and 85,000
depending on the position that I would
get all right that sounds about right
and what's the long-term play in
technology for you where do you want to
go um i' I'd want to be um honestly my
dream job would be to be coding and
developing analytics um software for
professional uh football programs okay
great so you have a huge upside so the
answer is not just simply no but it's
not necessary for you to take out a loan
$133,000 if you really commit to this
and you come up with some incredibly
intense ways of selling things three
four five jobs you should cash flow this
and and and and move forward so you
you're going to go find an additional
$133,000 to pay your way through this
and see that income increase and get
through the baby steps faster but don't
go into debt for it it's not necessary
the boot camp will always be there how
much so if you got to wait you got to
wait how much debt do you now
have um the quote unquote only debt that
we have is a is my Master's Degree which
is 39,000 in debt your Masters is in
what uh music education but I'm
unfortunately no longer able to um
continue in
that
why um I had uh some bad choices that
made and I'm just not able to continue
teaching right now oh you can't you
can't teach in the
classroom that's correct but you still
have a masters in
music correct I still have the license
yes
okay all right
so is uh what you've done made it
illegal for you to tutor people on an
individual
basis um no sir okay all right and so
you can make serious Bank doing that you
know that
right I would I would open a music
tutoring School immediately private
lessons immediately 50 bucks an hour and
I'd go get me 13,000
bucks you
there yes I am sir sorry that's okay all
right I
mean uh traditional classroom teachers
tutoring in traditional subjects are
making anywhere from $30 to $50 an hour
uh you can do online tutoring you can do
in-person private lessons music lessons
of different kinds and tutoring and with
that degree if you have basic music
ability and I'm guessing you do for
goodness sakes then um I'm opening a
tutoring business right now and I'm
going to go like crazy all the time
doing nothing but that um I think you
got put in the in time out BAS B on what
you did from what you thought you were
going to be and so you you Ste back and
you accepted a $38,000 position as a
reality and I don't think that's the
reality I don't think that's a reality
it's not and and I would also say that
beyond the music tutoring you're doing
anything and everything it doesn't
matter now $20 an hour job $25 an hour
job you're doing it three four five of
them to get the 13,000 you can amass
that pretty quick those numbers add up
get yourself a calculator and literally
write down how many hours how much money
per month can I make do I need to make
to quickly get 13,000 do the or to get
the first half or the first half start
the coding and get the other half while
you're finishing that's right while
you're in class what the idea here is is
that the boot camp will be there and so
will the technology opportunities so
don't further your debt don't put
yourself further behind when you don't
have to there's zero reason to do this
see the the other thing is this the the
the overall concept Ben and for the rest
of you out there
the only time that the debt system works
is if everything
works and everything never
works so I went $39,000 in debt to get
my Master's Degree and my dream
job only it doesn't work mhm yeah and
now here I sit and I'm making 38,000 and
I can't justify the 39,000 that I spent
in student loans to get a master's
degree in music Ed
uh because it doesn't work out life
never goes down this like this little
cute little yellow brick road Follow the
yellow brick road I mean you just really
you you can't keep it it
there's you know the problem with going
to see The Wizard of Oz is there's
flying monkeys between here and there
that's the problem and so you you C you
got to count on the flying monkeys
they're part of the program and so when
you do that all of a sudden the debt
looks doesn't look so delicious but when
you assume everything's is a clean path
of and everyone's following the speed
limit and no one's talking on their cell
phone while they're driving beside you
and no one's eating a Big Mac while
they're driving beside you and no one is
putting on their makeup while they're
driving beside you and so there's never
any danger on the highway when you make
that assumption in order for your debt
idea to play out you've set yourself up
for the flying monkeys you're going to
get you're going to get hit and that's
what happened to Ben on the first round
and I don't want that to happen to him
on the second round so pay cash for it
on the second round even if the flying
monkeys knock you off you don't have any
debt that's exactly right I got the
education but I don't have any debt
that's right and so let's go do it let's
go pay for it roll up your sleeves work
like a wild man all you're going to be
doing Ben is working that's it just work
work work work work work work work work
work work and you don't have to worry
you won't die from it right before you
die from hard work you'll pass out don't
worry about it that's right someone will
be there to catch you by the way there's
a return on effort when we don't have to
take a loan out that we're going to just
in the distance pay off we say I've got
to gut it out hustle it out big time to
come up with 13 Grand to change my life
boy the return on that effort is so much
better you're going to find yourself
paying better attention by the way in
boot camp yeah most people get better
grades in grad school than they did in
beer pong school yeah also known as
undergrad this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsay we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level Nets week gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today ah love this guy I love
his books I'm so glad I got to hang out
with him today back at Christmas uh two
different people gave me the book
Comfort crisis if two people give you a
book even if it's on weight loss you
should take it seriously and comfort
crisis is a serious book it is a great
read and I got to know Michael through
that and I had him on with Mike row and
I and a couple other guys as we're
talking about the status of work ethic
the state or the I don't know the
condition of lack of work ethic in
America today we did an event on that uh
a few months ago that was highly
successful so when we heard Michael was
going to be in town we put him on a
bunch of our podcast and ask him to stop
in here on his new book scarcity brain
welcome my friend thanks for having me
and congratulations on the huge success
on both of these books Comfort crisis is
uh you know it kind of came on a little
bit late it was a late bloomer but it's
become a huge book yeah like a good
horse man it breaks late I guess yeah um
I was surpr I was as surprised as you
are I'm not surprised I'm just uh I I
love a book that breaks late like that
cuz that means it's got legs it'll be
with us for a while cuz the contents is
so so strong okay so scarcity
brain versus obviously abundance brain I
guess yeah yeah exactly the both sides
of it but the the human lizard brain for
survival teaches us to think scarcity
first right correct we hone in on
scarcity we're very sensitive to
scarcity cues which is basically pieces
of information in our environment that
make us think things are scarce and our
reaction is to acquire more more I think
I'm hungry but it's really I'm just low
on sugar yes you think you're hungry
you're low on sugar you think you need
to buy that third thing on Amazon Prime
for the day and so you do it you think
you need more information so you spend
more time on Twitter on and on and on
all these things um that I think we
overdo in life today um track back to
that they were things that would have
given us a survival advantage in the
past it does lead us to obesity it does
lead us to materialism the loop the
scarcity Loop the scarcity brain this
constant striving to do something that's
totally not I don't need to eat again I
just ate and I sure don't need to eat 12
more Donuts I just had one I mean you
know I don't need to buy another gun my
wife said but I did I bought another one
and so you know but I mean what is it
about that how's that work well I like
to say that everyone knows that
everything is fine in
moderation yet why are we all so bad
about it bad at it right right and um I
do think that these Tendencies we have
when we overdo things it's usually with
things that would have given us a
survival advantage in the past so for
all of time pretty much everything you
needed to survive was scarce and hard to
find food food safety safety
information community community even
status the number of people that you
could influence um possessions right
tools mhm so we sort of sounds like a
video game so yeah so we default to more
of those if you were the type of person
that defaulted to more of those you
would survive now the difference is that
we sort of have that ancient drive for
more in a world where we have an
abundance of all those things and we
don't necessarily have a good Governor
that tells us oh you've had enough food
or you own enough
guns or you've got enough information on
this event unfolding in the world and
you don't need to spend all night up
till 3:00 a.m. scrolling Twitter to get
the next Little Death scrolling yes
death scrolling
exactly so why how do we get stuck in
this Loop do you think well I think that
one thing that's interesting is that um
technology has really pushed us into
more it knows what is going to work to
get us to overc consume I was part of
this book I went into a uh casino in Las
Vegas that is brand new it's Cutting
Edge uh but it's not open to the public
it is a casino laboratory that is used
entirely for human behavior research now
if you think about something that people
overdo over over and over it's a slot
machine mhm right and so they've really
unpacked completely illogically
completely illogically but they do it
anyway yeah um so I identify what I call
the scarcity Loop and it is a sort of
ultimate Behavior loop at pushing us
into more and you can think of a slot
machine so it's got three parts it's got
opportunity unpredictable rewards and
quick repeatability you got an
opportunity to get something of value
that enhances your life unpredictable
rewards you know you'll get that thing
of value at some point if you keep
repeating the behavior but you don't
know when you don't know how valuable
it's going to be so with the slot
machine it's like if you keep playing
you'll eventually get a win but you
don't know how big it'll be right and
then quick repeatability you can repeat
the behavior over and over now the
reason um that this is important to know
because it doesn't just apply to slot
machines it's in all these different
technological systems and institutions
that really kind of determine how we
spend our time our Attention our
resources so this Loop is being put in
social media it's what makes social
media work the dopamine hit yeah it
makes uh dating apps work it drives a
lot of online shopping Behavior it's in
the rise of sports gambling it's being
put in certain fin personal finance apps
and on and on and on and it's made the
online porn industry the largest
industry in the world exactly exactly
and so in you know in the past this
wasn't a thing that was just part of our
life at the um at the scope and scale
that it is now but because we spend so
much of our Lives on screens Now it's 12
to 13 hours a day engaged with digital
media it has this ability to sort of
creep into our life and um push us into
behaviors that I think um although can
be fun in the short term they always
they're always fun they're always fun in
the short term uh but can hurt us in the
long run so how do you flip that and go
to from this false scarcity that put you
into a loop and go to an abundance
mentality well I think first of all if
you have a behavior that you keep doing
over and over and over and that is
hurting you in the long run um to be
aware that it probably does fall into
the scarcity Loop uh this leverages what
researchers call the Hawthorn effect so
if you can observe a behavior it usually
changes the behavior just by knowing
that oh this is happening I'm doing this
like you'll start to change and then
second you can change any of the three
parts of the loop so you can change the
opportunity you can slow down the quick
repeatability so an example is if you're
the type of person that is buying too
much dumb stuff on the internet even
just having a rule that I'm only making
my purchases in person that inserts a
pause because you have to get into your
car you have to drive down to the store
and then you have to scour the aisles to
find that item and in that time you
probably realize I didn't even need this
thing in the first place I forgot what I
was here for I forgot what I was here
for one of the things that you
discovered in this book that I found
fascinating is there is a way to
actually Thrive with enough which is in
your subtitle you call it a very
unlikely Hack That You discovered what
is that oh the
yeah so I think that um so when you look
at okay why do we why is this scarcity
Loop so attractive to humans it probably
helped us uh find food in the past so if
you think about the past if you uh you
needed food right H that was going to
allow you to survive and so you go to
one point no food the next point no food
the next Point jackpot food that's the
exact same architecture as a slot
machine um you can use this Loop in
habits that enhance your life so for
example um you hunt mhm hunting is the
exact same system right you know you're
going out there to get an animal there's
your opportunity you know you'll
probably see an animal at some point but
you don't know how big you don't know if
it'll be the right one you don't know if
it'll be old enough you don't know all
these things and when you find that
there's a gamble too like am I going to
be able to pull the trigger in the right
spot right and then you can repeat that
annually whatever but along the way
instead of a slot machine where you're
sitting in a casino you know you're
surrounded by smoke you're indoors when
when you're hunting you're outside
that's good for us you're also being
Physically Active that's good for us
you're probably hunting with other
people that's good for us so you're
getting all these ancillary benefits and
um you see it in hunting uh you could
see this in through fishing even things
like uh foraging so Foodies will Forge
for mushrooms but even something as
simple as like you know what I'm really
into uh collecting vinyl and there's
this album that is really hard to find
and I'm just going to walk around my
city that I live in and I'm going to go
from vinyl store to vinyl store and see
if I can find this thing and that'll be
an exciting way to spend my my time uh
okay break the cycle Michael Easter the
way we discovered him was through
Comfort crisis the new book fix your
craving mindset rewire your habits to
thrive with enough it's called scarcity
brain highly recommend it I will be
absorbing this this weekend I have not
gotten to it until now and I will
immediately good stuff absolutely great
honored to have you on the show my
friend congratul ulations on these great
works thank you very much for having me
I appreciate it check it out Michael
Easter Easter michael.com and you can
follow him on social Med media at
Michael Easter this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see see why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 40% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions we have a stage it's called
the debt free stage if you stand on that
stage it can only mean one thing well at
least posibly could only mean one thing
you're debt free Tommy and Heather are
standing on that stage congratulations
guys thank you where do you guys where
do you guys live uh right now we live in
Parish Florida but we're originally from
torington in Connecticut ah fun well
welcome to Nashville good to have you
how much debt have you guys paid off it
was uh
112 and change 112,000 how long did this
take uh just over uh two years and 3
months okay and um what was your range
of income during that time it would uh
it started at 110 and ended at 150 cool
what do youall do for a living um so
before we relocated to Florida we uh
worked in a syringe Factory mhm in
Connecticut and uh with Co we had a lot
of business so there was unlimited
overtime mhm and in 2020 we decided to
go get our real estate license okay and
uh yeah our first year we had 14 sales
mhm so that took off and um and moved to
Florida to do that no we sold houses in
Connecticut and it was just this past
July that we moved to Florida okay
you're doing real estate there not yet
but we're going to be okay all right
cool well way to go guys okay what kind
of debt was the 112,000 oh my God what
wasn't the
debt let's see credit cards um cars
cars solar panels my son's braces cell
phones cell phones iPads you were normal
yeah unfortun and normal in America
sucks doesn't it it does absolutely so
what woke you up 2 years and 3 months
ago and how didd you get connected to
all this ramsy stuff so
uh truth be known this whole thing
started like right when we first met I
uh I have a history with addiction and
she walked into my life at a time frame
when everybody else was walking away for
that reason um happy to say that October
7th I celebrated 11 years of sobriety a
congratulations but unfortunately when
the uh using stopped the spending began
switched it out for a different one
pretty much and um yeah so for for years
and years it's basically what happened I
just we would spend on everything and
anything she takes half the
accountability for it but 95% of it was
me I'll be the first one to tell you
that um what are you what were you
addicted to before that you've been dry
11 years alcohol and uh painkillers okay
well congratulations thank you sir
that's a huge Victory you're a powerful
guy to do that that's uh not everybody
can do what you've done and very proud
of you all right thanks and now you've
applied it started applying the whole
concept to uh the other parts of your
life huh yeah so um uh as far as us
being introduced to
you uh I had a friend of mine Joey
Schwarz and his wife Ruby who' been
telling me about you for a long time and
uh right after we got our real estate
license and all that stuff he comes up
to me and he says hey Tommy you need to
get on this Dave Ramsey plant or however
he talks and uh I hope he doesn't talk
like that
so he says he keeps telling me about it
and I thought it was just one of those
get-rich quick things yeah so um but any
the opposite get rich slow yeah so he uh
he was telling me about it and he stay
at me about it he's like between real
estate and all the overtime that you're
working he's like you're going to be a
millionaire in a few years I'm like yeah
whatever shut up so um it was
2021 after our first year in real estate
um we wound up getting Dave you're going
to kill me for this uh we got our
generous Biden bucks as you call it now
you would think $5,600 I'd be smart and
pay off two of my credit cards that are
maxed out at 2500 each no we're going to
take the kids to Vegas and that's what
we did and this is where the big moment
happened so when we get there the
limousine picks us up at the airport I'm
getting a Camaro the next day we got a
room with a volcano View and we get to
the hotel and I don't have money to
cover the
incidentals so my daughter my
17-year-old daughter who was with us and
my son she had to uh pick it up so we
can eat for the week and our first three
days that we were there I I I didn't
even feel like I was there I'm I just I
was like beside myself I'm like you even
realize what a freaking loser you just
made yourself look like in front of your
kids just now and that was it and it was
the following Saturday we were back home
we're getting ready to go to her
sister's house she was in the shower and
I'm scrolling through my YouTube feet
I'm like yeah seen this watch that don't
care y yada and then I come across this
five things that'll make you wealthy
video and it says Dave Ramsey I'm like
hey this is the guy that Joey keeps
telling me about so I'm looking down at
my uh I'm looking down at my phone and
I'm looking right at you and I'm like
all right Hot Shot you got about 90
seconds to sell me on this Dave you
didn't even need 30 seconds I'm like I'm
in
so uh yeah we got to oh and then there's
the part that you said uh oh yeah
you the uh what was it oh yeah you know
what the Republicans and Democrats have
in have in common neither one of them
can freaking add I freaking texted Joey
I'm like I'm
in that was the statement that was it Y
how intense did it get quickly I from
this moment to the moment you guys start
this journey how intense was it for you
guys oh very int I mean I've I've always
been like a workaholic so it wasn't
anything that I wasn't really used to
but I mean her and I we would work like
12-hour shifts and then we'd go out and
show houses yeah you got the gazelle's
on the shirts so you know about it yeah
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of Deb is so as I said um I
mean I've been down this road twice with
using and with spending MH um for me the
two key components number one is
accountability MH you got to look in the
mirror and like David gogins once says
you know the accountability mirror every
day that you make an excuse is just
another day you don't have to do
anything about it um so accountability
is big and perseverance man
just and being on the same page exactly
if we weren't on the same page it
wouldn't have worked at all yeah yeah
way to go you two I'm proud of you proud
of you well done very well done how's it
feel to be
free
he how's it feel to be have him where
he's saying I'm not going to spend us
into the poor house it's a big deal it
is it's a big deal I mean that's a big
thing for your marriage big day for big
thing for you to respect your husband
when he does stuff like I mean that's
that's manly that's well done both of
you I'm proud of you excellent excellent
job working together pulling this off
and uh pushing pushing it through and uh
phenomenal hey we've got the uh live and
give box for you it's got the baby steps
Mill millionaires book in it that's your
next stop uh The Total Money Makeover
book to give to somebody who's inspired
by your story Financial Peace University
membership as well you can enjoy these
things or give them away that's what
they're for a lot of people buy the Box
just to take some of it and use it and
take some of it and give it so we want
it to give it to you guys to say thanks
for coming out we appreciate you coming
in from Florida to do your debt free
scream Tommy and Heather St Petersburg
Florida
$112,000 paid off two years and 3 months
making 110 to 150 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three 2 one
we're
free
[Applause]
yeah that's
it you know the money thing is not as
serious as the substance addiction thing
but the parallels in changing it or is
it still there yeah and the the
parallels between what's underneath the
problem and and it's so important for us
to understand that when we want stuff
and we put it on a credit card because
we can't wait for it we we there's
something deeper going on and
understanding what's really going on you
said this so effectively for decades is
that uh I'm the problem in the mirror
the person I'm looking at who I'm
shaving like I'm the problem something
is is going on with me in my heart and
in my head that's making me live beyond
what I can live under and that's what's
going on and he recognized it twice and
and beat it twice incredible story
looking for love in all the wrong places
there it is clicking prime prime prime
prime prime yeah oh wait I still don't
feel any better isn't that weird who
knew yeah that's how this works this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days
Christian Healthcare Ministries gives
members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at ch ministri .org
[Music]
[Applause]
budget Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
number one bestselling author of from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
Allison is in San Diego hi Allison
welcome to the ramsy
show hi hello hi what's
up so I'm calling because I have about
$116,000 um in credit card debt uh maybe
a little bit a little bit over 16,000
and
177,000 in student loans so a total of
like
33,000 um $700 in debt total debt um and
the problem is that my credit cards the
balances on those I've had them for
years um and the interest is really high
on some of them it's like 30% on some of
them it's like 24 and the balances just
don't go down so what I'm wondering is
whether I should um maybe ask for like a
loan um like a maybe a personal loan
from one of my family members to tackle
one and then start
um slowly tackling the other ones I just
got a new job and doubled my income oh
that's great what do you
make um I'm gonna start making about
$6,000 per month I'm gonna say
more and you were making about
3,000 I was making about 3,000 yes okay
and so if you keep leaving living like
you were living on 3,000 and you put
3,000 a month towards the debt you'd be
out of debt in a
year
true
um I mean I do have my the only issue
now is that I do have a commute and the
gas is really expensive it's about an
hour and a half commute every day um
sounds like you need to
move 200 I that is the plan yeah in
about a year my daughter's in SCH would
you wait a year why would you drive an
hour and a half for a
year
because my I share custody with my
daughter's dad in um the hometown the
town that I live in
and um that's it's you know it's a legal
thing that I have to go through or we
have to figure something
out but for now my daughter is you she's
for three hours a day I'm G to figure
something
out yeah I I mean I have figured
something out to where one one week week
that she's with her dad Alison borrowing
money
will not get you out of debt you can't
borrow your way out of debt interest
rates are not your problem finding a way
to not pay $3,000 a month on this debt
for 11 months is your
problem you need to find a way to pay
$3,000 a month instead of finding a way
to not pay $3,000 a month that's what
you've done so far you've now got this
fabulous Moment In Time
where your income has shot way up let's
find reasons and ways to make to take
advantage of that and get this mess
cleaned up you can't borrow your way out
of debt this is not an interest rate
problem this is an Allison
problem it is yeah you're
right you're you're a smart lady and you
know all this so because I tried to do
this for years I tried to borrow my way
out of debt I tried to out earn my
stupid stupidity I try to do all this
but finally one day I just said that's
it there's only one way to pay get out
of debt is pay it off I got to pay it
off that's how I get out of debt I got I
got I need
$33,000 that's 3,000 a month for 11
months oh there's some interest so it's
going to take me 12 okay but it's still
going to get yeah oh whatever and I got
some G my gas bills higher and I'm
commuting oh well maybe I'm not or maybe
I am a couple days a week or maybe I
don't know is there another way to do
this I got to find a way I got to find a
way to put $3,000 a mon month on this I
got $3,000 a month I didn't have before
I got this new job I got a you see what
I'm doing yeah well there's an old
phrase where there's a will there's a
away and and it's really true it's not
just a a nice little saying on a quilted
you know thing in a country store I mean
it's it's really that we begin to see
opportunities when we do what you just
said Dave when we actually say I have to
find a way so I keep looking looking
looking looking looking and things that
Solutions
opportunities that weren't seen before
are all of a sudden seen and it is just
that simple seek and you will find I
mean that is the goal right here for her
the way I changed my mindset was I
always you know take it pretend like
there's some kind of whacked out tragedy
which is not really happening but go
with me for a minute those of you that
have children that you like okay let's
pretend one of them was ill and you
needed $33,000 to save their
life yeah watch out and you had to do it
in two years mhm and you
you you would not find reasons to not do
it you would find reasons to do
it Hell hath no fury like someone trying
to save the life of their child that's
really good and what that means is is
that you can do this it just has to
become a priority in that case in that
bizarre tragic situation which doesn't
really exist but if it did exist you
would find a way you'd find a will where
there's a will there's a way yeah and
you know we're going to figure this out
we're not losing this kit we're going to
go you know you can't have you ever seen
somebody that didn't like the diagnosis
they got they go to about 16 doctors so
they get a diagnosis they like or
treatment plan that's going to work
instead of everybody going you're going
to die you're going to die you're going
to die and they find some kind of
alternative something or other weird
thing and I don't know some witch doctor
claps their hands twice and spins around
or whatever but they find a way right
it's corre and you know cuz I'm not
going to I don't accept this and and
when you read that point that you go
I've had it yeah that's where it changes
Al yeah and that's what I need you to do
here um in instead of using this new job
as a just some extra margin in life it
needs to clean up your mess yeah and you
need to cut up those stupid credit cards
get you some scissors out tonight light
a candle have a plastic surgery party
Maria is in New York hi Maria welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hi thank thanks for taking my call
can you hear me okay yes what's
up okay so I started listening to you
guys about a month ago and I'm on baby
step 4 um so I currently consider um
sorry contribute 10% to my employer is
Roth 401k which is the max to get the
match um so I want to increase that and
my question is should I contribute more
to that Roth 401k should I contribute to
a separate IRA account
are the options inside your 401k good
options they're pretty good yeah well
that's not
exciting I mean if they've got good
long-term track records yes just
increase your not above your match and
get to
15% uh if not then you can go open an
individual Roth IRA with a Ramsey
smartvestor Pro click smartvestor at
Ramsey solutions.com find the people we
recommend for investing and they can
help you set up a personal Roth IRA uh
and pick help you pick out some good
mutual funds that you feel good about
you'll learn about stuff in the process
of doing that which is kind of cool I'd
probably do that just for that reason
but you're you're on to something here
what we tell people is it's kind of rock
paper scissors except there's only one
way to win it's
um match beats Roth beats
traditional in your case you've got a
match up to 10 and you're going to take
that and you've got it in a Ro which is
a double dip that's awesome and you can
do Roth beyond that to get to 15% either
in an individual or at your company if
you're not excited about the options at
your company then go get an individual
Roth for the balance of that other 5% of
your income going in uh but if you're if
it if your uh options are decent and you
want to just stay with one simple plan
you just increase what you're doing at
work and then you don't have to think
about it again yeah and I I think the
key here is is what's my long-term goal
and understanding what we teach she's
new to the show and so I just want to
point out that you've taught all the
Ramsey personalities as we've learned so
try to learn what you know if we look at
the long-term effects of the stock
market and the investing that plan there
that Little Rock Bay procision I love
that it works and it works all the time
you have to stay with it and so she's
brand new and I'm just getting back to
you to tell her once you get on this
plan stay in it that is the key don't
get off when we hear these you know the
your your analogy that's so powerful as
the roller coaster yeah well you would
if you were not invested in the last 12
months you would have missed out on a 15
plus 15 plus% rate of return yeah wow in
good mutual funds that's the last 12
months nobody's talking about that
everybody's talking about what mortgage
interest rates are right the dead gum
stock market is skyrocketing and you're
not you're not even on the ride come
on that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the
books
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the ramsy way go to
Ramsey solutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's ramseys
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships open phones atle
88255 225 Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
number one bestselling author of the
book from paycheck to purpose talking
about careers and jobs he's my sidekick
today my co-host open phones here8
825-5222
things ouch that doesn't sound fun
what's going on
kiddo well I would say 2022 there was a
death in the family and that's kind of
where it started and
then
um my
fiance um was I guess was let go from
his job because he was having a hard
time with the loss but we all were and
then we decided to to start our business
and so business is going fine and then I
got laid off for my full-time job which
was which was kind of surprising so now
we're at a point where it's like all
right neither one of us have like the
full-time job but we've just been
working our businesses and they've uh
had some popup problems here and there
and so it's definitely causing a lot of
issues who passed away I didn't
know it was uh my fiance's brother's
wife okay that's certainly a tragedy
tragedy it's certainly a hard thing to
get past and that was uh three years
ago that was no just last year oh last
year okay and uh your fiance when are
you all getting married how long's he
been your
fiance it was supposed to be this July
but I
actually got laid off then so I was like
well they don't let laid off people get
married I
mean I didn't feel like that would make
sense to uh it made sense to start a
business well we had already had the
plans and did everything to start the
yeah you kind of already had a plan to
get married anyway okay so how much does
your fiance say make it his job or his
business well uh well it's our business
it was a it was a t business and also he
has another property where he's a
landlord and has tenants that's not a
job
would you have one property in tenants
that doesn't take 10 minutes that's not
a job okay so how much does he
make well he did have a job and no honey
he started a business how much money
does he make nothing that's what he
makes okay right you wouldn't be calling
me if he was making 100 degree
year so I guess just um wait stop you
just drove past stop let's stop right
where we were your fiance is not making
any money am I correct yes or
no
from right now darling right now you got
no money cuz you got laid off and his
business is not a business it's a hobby
he does not make any money am I
wrong no okay yeah probably not much
okay so he needs to get a job and you
need to get a
job and all of the sudden y'all will
have
income and quit calling this sitting on
my butt a
business Danielle you guys are in Tampa
Florida you you guys need to be working
multiple jobs if you can't get a really
good uh job in the industry that you
were in we need to be bringing in income
this is a
GameChanger yeah the question on my
screen says how can I handle my finances
after losing my job and the answer is
get six
jobs right no we do have um we do uh a
turo we do that's where you're renting
your car out to people that's like
you're just using your car as a rental
car
yes well we have actual two cars on the
platform that aren't either one of our
cars right my but my point is you're in
a rental car business and it's there's
not enough margin in that so you're not
making any money yeah that's not that's
not a company you're using an app to to
rent your
cars right
well that's a great side hustle if you
got it and the cars are paid for but
it's not a side hustle right but we
don't need side hustles right now we
need seven side hustles or six as Dave
said or or fulltime full-time job what
were you making at your last
job I would say
about four four uh Grand a month okay
what were you
doing I was doing um I was a quality
engineering
technician and why did they fire
you no it was a layoff the whole
the whole
shift got laid off so there was only one
shift okay all right so you need to
replace that income with a good core
career and quit messing around the side
with I'm a landlord and I rent out my
cars and calling that a way to make a
living because you're not making a
living you wouldn't have called me if
you and your fiance were making serious
Bank so you're in your problem is not a
outgo I'm struggling with debt my
finances are out of control issue your
problem is you don't have any income and
the great news is there's a tremendous
labor shortage in America right now yeah
and lots of people hiring and we're
going into Christmas season yeah and
listen Dave if there are some debt on
those cars which many times people are
carrying car payments on these cars and
then renting them just like they would
do a house I would sell the cars move if
the if you have some equity in those
cars move the cars get out of the turo
business get rid of the debt if you own
them free and clear Danielle sell them
anyway and get yourself some some a
little bit of a cushion get an emergency
fund get employed pay off any debt work
the baby steps you've got to get out of
this turo business I just it long term
it's just not a good play because you've
got an asset of a car it's not an asset
it just continues to go down in value
and you hope that you can rent it out
enough to people who fly buying a Tampa
and don't want to rent from any other
rental car agency it just is fraught
with all kinds of problems your fiance
may need to sit down with a good
counselor and help him unpack because he
might be depressed he might be
struggling with the grief at a
unbelievable level that's affecting his
whole life now and he may need to sit
down with somebody and unpack that
because what I hear in your all's whole
story is we want to figure out a way to
have money without
working that's your whole story that you
told me on the phone and and now that I
got laid off it kind of uhoh this
doesn't work so you guys have got to go
back to work you got to get your career
start bringing home the
bacon and sometimes that may be because
of the death that you guys have been
through and The Grieving around that
that's fair but in the meantime you got
to get your life back Kido this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Paul is in Portland Oregon
hey Paul welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up so uh my my wife wife and I we
have a we own a house uh we refinanced a
couple years ago when interest rates
were good and got locked in at around
3% and now uh she and I disagree a
little bit on how we should use some of
our investment money I think we should
put the um put it towards 401k and Ira
and other retirement Investments whereas
she would like to pay down the mortgage
sooner um My Philosophy is the uh 401k
Ira uh should give a better than a 3%
return so it's a little bit of a better
investment in the long run but I wanted
to hear your
opinion okay well we teach people to do
both and the process that we use has led
millions of people into a situation
where they're
wealthy uh and the process we call the
baby steps and the first goal is to
become debt free other than your home
that's baby steps one and two to then
three is have an emergency fund of 3 to
6 months of expenses I assume you've
done those things before you asked this
question is that right yeah that's
correct you don't have any debt and you
have an emergency fund except your house
right correct okay and then that brings
us to Baby Steps four five and six which
we do
simultaneously baby step four is put 15%
of your income into retirement first to
the match if there is a match at work uh
second to Roth and third to traditional
if it takes that to get up to
15% baby step five while you're doing
that is you start doing something
towards kids college if that's
appropriate and then six is all other
monies that were not spending on life
above 15% going into Investments pay
down the home because you want to have
both a paid for home and a large nest
egg in the 401K the millionaires that we
have studied those are the two primary
things that they did to become
Millionaires and we did the largest
study of millionaires ever done in North
America a couple of years ago and that
was our findings so all that to say is
you're both right um but at at around
those numbers and that structure so
what's your household
income uh it's my income is 110 and hers
is variable it's uh she's a substitute
teacher so it's a few hundred among
okay so so you make like 130,000 a
year roughly yeah okay 15 how old are
you uh 31 okay 15% of that if you never
do anything else in good mutual funds in
your 401k in a Roth with a match
particularly on portion of it will make
you extremely wealthy by the time you're
65 years old like $10 million is what
the math will come
out yeah currently I'm putting 20% with
a 4% match all then what I'm telling you
to do is I would back it down to 15 and
I'd throw the rest at the
mortgage okay and I'd get that house
paid off because it's one of the two
elements for the first $1 to5 million of
net worth that people come up with and
you get that house paid off then you
don't have any payments now you're
freeing up your most powerful wealth
building tool which is your income
meanwhile you've been getting a match
meanwhile you're putting you know what
177,000 bucks year 18,000 bucks 1,500
bucks a month give or take is 15% of
your all's income you're going to be
unbelievably Rich if you never do
anything else but certainly we'll have
the house paid for in a few years and
then we'll be able to put even more
towards everything and the whole
stinking thing mathematically just blows
up in a wonderful way but uh so you're
both right in that sense but would I
ever uh never pay extra on the house and
keep the Home Mortgage no because we
found that the typical millionaire
doesn't do that the number millionaires
that we talked to that said you know the
way I got rich was I didn't ever pay off
my house I put it all into Investments
almost none almost none they did both
they invested and they got their house
paid off that's the thing we see that's
the two big things we see other stuff
around the edges of it but that if you
want to plow right through the middle of
what these people do that's it they get
the house paid off and they invest
steadily not one or the other yeah and
and by the way at 31 years of age I love
that we're hearing this question because
this is exactly what we look at when we
talk to Everyday millionaire excuse me
baby steps millionaires in our theme
hours and we were on last week together
and just one after another one after
another they played the long game that
we teach and this 31y old is going to be
there well he you know we didn't ask
about the house value and the balance on
it but we're more dealing with the
concept but mathematically he'll be
there in about a decade yeah 41 for his
first million yeah yeah and and then we
go from there so yeah that that's a
pretty cool place place to be yeah
Andrew is in Orlando hi Andrew welcome
to the Ramsey Show hi Dave thanks for
having me sure what's
up uh so I recently got a promotion at
my current job I work in the hospitality
field um I'm making $18 an hour now um
and the company I work for is about to
see a lar of large growth uh from now
until
2025 um but I'm interested in possibly
going back to school um I do already
have two degrees um both are in music
performance I use them for my side
hustle where I'm teaching um marching
bands on the side and writing music but
I'm interested in possibly going back to
school to get something in the data
analytics side of things and to transfer
departments in my company into the data
analytics side and I'm just kind of
looking for advice as to if I should go
back to school or not probably not but I
want you to understand why I'm saying
that you don't have to get a four-year
degree to get hired into data analytics
there are so many boot camps and
certification programs where you can
spend a whole lot less money and a lot
less time and that's great for you
because you're now a professional and
you're in with this company and I would
also tell you that if you find a
reputable uh opportunity and take it to
your company leaders and say hey I love
this company I'm in the hospitality game
right now but I want to move over into
the technology side of this company I
want to be with you guys long term at
would you be willing to reimburse or pay
for my tuition and because you are so
valuable to them now and you're going to
be adding technology skills you could
very well get this paid for by your
company but even if you didn't it's a
whole lot less money to go get that uh
through a boot camp or through legit
programs like bethl Tech which we
endorse here uh than going back to four
years of school you've already done your
time with two-year degree uh two degrees
you don't need a full four-year degree
in technology to do that
work yeah and so that makes complete
sense um which I'm glad to hear uh with
that um the company does pay for
schooling but they won't pay for boot
camps and you said just kind of approach
them um I I guess I would have to figure
out who to approach within the company
um is if they don't if they would not
reimburse it is that something um I know
you guys I I about $6,000 of debt right
now in credit cards I know D decision
would be to go into more debt for more
school well first of all let's so what I
would tell you to do is pay off your
debt uh the the technology
qualifications and certifications that's
all going to be waiting for you uh
you're fine you're young you're on your
way you're in with the company you want
to be with this gives you a chance now
to show them uh the value that you have
and go ahead and pay off the debt pay
off the debt and then save up the money
or cash flow your way through your
budget each month and and go get the the
the work done because let me tell you
something even if they won't pay for it
you'll get all that money back and then
some yeah I but I I think um I'm going
to spend a little time with the folks
over in the data side yeah and say I'd
really like to be over here I'm about
one certification or boot camp away from
being valuable to you if you guys will
help me with that we're going to be game
on yeah and you know it's uh I don't pay
for boot camps at Ramsey I do pay for
education at Ramsey but if you come into
our one of our leaders office with a
reason to do something yeah that's going
to give you make you more valuable while
you're here we will pay for the tool you
know I mean we do it all the time and we
may be getting hung up too on boot camp
I'm using that generally speaking maybe
just a certification program just a
legitimate program there are legitimate
programs that aren't technical boot
camps you need to do your research on
that do exactly what Dave said but take
them options and go this program this
program and this program cost this much
take this amount of time and I'm want to
do it to be on your team would you be
willing to help me and I think you're
going to be surprised at what you might
hear yeah I wouldn't take my first no or
a policy decision on that i' be knocking
on the door till somebody answered this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home Buy higher Edge from Churchill
gives you an advantage over those other
guys go to Churchill mortgage.com today
to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage aby's
with us hi Abby how are you hi better
than I deserve how are you better than I
deserve welcome where do you live
Frederick Maryland how fun well thanks
for being with us thanks for hanging out
how much debt have you paid off
$67,900 range of income during that time
44,000 to 68,000 okay and what kind of
debt was the 68,000 student loans and a
car ah okay cool how old are you 27 I
turned 28 in December okay so this
journey starts when you're 21 yes tell
us about it and how did you get
connected to us yeah so back uh in 2011
when I was in high school my parents
took
FPU and I remember in my bedroom having
envelopes on the back of my door where I
had to put cash that I would get for
allowance and things like that into
different categories hardcore exactly I
know they're so tough aren't they um but
it it invested that principle to me in
the beginning and then I went to college
and then after college I graduated in
2017 and my parents had been starting to
take it more seriously and I was unsure
exactly of where all my money was going
I knew generally how much I should have
or how much I was spending but I didn't
really know for sure and I was living at
home for a few years years to help pay
off my debt um and so that's where it
really started I wanted to get rid of it
right away and not wait till I was in my
40s and 50s to pay all the stuff off
when I was single and um living at home
to try to pay off as much as I could so
I got started then and really took it
seriously I took Financial Peace in 2020
um we had to go virtual in March right
when Co started so I took that in 2020
and then I've just been getting after it
uh ever since so that's kind of how I
got started so a lot of this has been
the last three years yeah yeah a big
bulk of it has absolutely all right so
you go from high school student where
your nerdy dad made you have envelopes
on the back of the door I love nerdy dad
there you go and but then still go get a
car loan and a student loan yeah they
how's that happen they were they said we
were just talking about it before I came
on they were like yeah we weren't really
taking it seriously until about 2017
2016 so okay so they were a little
except for the envelope part they were a
little little is I know exctly and then
that infected you yes ah okay I'll give
you a pass then okay that's cool it all
worked out all right and but the end of
the story is awesome absolutely very
cool so I love that this is a six-year
Journey for someone your age you stayed
with it you didn't get distracted you
know you stayed with it what's the key
if you were talking to other people your
age and they're going all right I'm
graduating with some student loan debt
or maybe they got the car whatever it is
we have a lot of young people joining
the show all the time what would you say
to them is the key to maybe your
generation sticking with this plan what
would you say to him yeah I have two
things that come to mind first of all my
faith is so big to me and this journey
taught me more about God's faithfulness
and provision than probably anything
else in my life so realizing that it's
not my money God actually trusts me with
this money and I'm to Steward it well
and so if I'm being Reckless that's not
being a good Steward so being able to
recognize that made it easier for me to
be sacrificial and let go of things
because it's not mine at the end of the
day um but secondly budgeting is just so
important like I said I knew previously
like vaguely how much money I was
spending but once my dad and I put
together a little Excel spreadsheet and
worked it all out and he got all the
formulas for me and everything um that
budget really really helps me and I look
forward to it every month and I tell all
my friends I'm doing my budget this
weekend and having to ask my roommates
to pay me back money for things so that
my budget can be equaled out you know
it's it's um it's challenging but it
really pays off in the end and being
able to say no to things like during Co
all of my stimulus checks $1,400 going
to a vantage hurt but wow was different
than all my other was that all that my
friends were doing with their stimulus
checks and things like that so I paid
during the whole pandemic um so just
that self denial of things that you
might want right here and now and
looking forward to the future so how's
it feel to be free it feels great it
feels so great with all the student loan
stuff coming back and not having a care
in the world I'm like not me exactly I'm
not signed up for your loser plan yes
exactly trying to tell my friends I'm
like get on this you can I was just
texting someone last night she's making
like so much money I'm like you could be
debt free in a year just do it it's
going to be tough it's going to be hard
but just stick with it and you got it so
I'm trying to inspire all my friends to
get on the TR how are they reacting to
the fact that their payments are now due
they're stressed people are very
stressed I think especially if you
weren't paying during the big pause it
feels like this big boulder coming at
you so they're they're really
overwhelmed and I actually think it's a
good
um thing for right now because my dad
and I are actually teaching FPU at my
church this spring and I lead a young
adults Ministry and so I'm trying to get
all of my friends to come and I'm like
guys you can get in control of this and
once you're in control and you know
what's going on your anxiety is going to
ease so much so yeah that's a big deal
congratulations thank you what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is um that that's sacrifice being
able to deny yourself and it's going to
be okay you don't need everything um
which is a hard concept to learn um but
it teaches you that you know that
self-sacrifice and again goes back to my
faith that Jesus died for me and denied
himself and so I can deny myself you
know a new pair of shoes or wanting to
go on a trip or something like that for
a longer goal that's going to be able to
let me bless other people Amen in the
long run so yeah well said very well
said well
congratulations other than mom and dad
who was cheering you on um my brother
and sister and Emily and then my
brother-in-law Scott Scott watches you
all the time he and I were going back on
the phone last night talking about
what's he going to say and he has all
your impersonations down pat so um oh my
impersonation yeah yeah he does a good
job he he really Nails it but so yeah my
family and then um my roommates they all
know and all my friends really all my
friends cheer me on I don't really have
too many people telling me that I'm
crazy or anything like that so that's
good yeah that's good it's one of the
reasons you win you got to be careful
who you have around you yes
you become who you hang around with so
well done well done congratulations
we're proud of you hero thank you very
good job hey we've got the live and give
box for you that's the baby steps
millionaires Bo book which is your next
stop amen for sure The Total Money
Makeover book and the Financial Peace
University membership and all of that
will work to help you in the ministry
that you're doing and for you to enjoy
as well thank you thanks for making the
trip from Maryland you're a fireball
you're fun thank you yeah it's been
awesome well done good job on the air
and man what a great story at uh uh 28
years old right 27 right I wanted to be
debt free before I turned 28 27 years
old exactly
68,000 paid off in 6 years making 40 to
68 Abby from Maryland count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three 2 1
I'm dead
free yeah
[Applause]
W now what is fascinating about her
story if you listen carefully to it and
this happens with a lot of debt free
call scream people that are in here on
the stage we hear this often uh she had
a six-year Journey but the majority of
it was done in three mhm Y and what was
the difference was it the income nope it
was her Outlook when she decided mhm
I can sacrifice a pair of shoes I can
sacrifice this to get control of my life
I can sacrifice I can sacrifice I can do
I can do needs and wants are different
things yeah I can get control of this
and once she decided that and then the
income came with it too man the last
three years it's like yeah boom well
there's something powerful to we know
this from tons of psychology studies to
put a date on something there's
something about about 28 years old yeah
and that really motivated her you could
tell that she she was like I oh I'm not
28 yet Dave cuz I said I was going to be
debt free and by Godly she did it and
there's something powerful about putting
and again life happens so I don't want
anybody thinking well it has to be by
that date but it certainly helps there's
something about seeing the Finish Line
we know this about Runners I only ran
One race Dave I retired you know cuz you
guilted me into One race but I learned
one thing having a Mark that you're
trying to hit does drive you towards it
you you want me to get out the world's
smallest violin now
where I guilted you into doing something
incredible called me but it was actually
great for me Le who came alongside you
in the last mile when you were
struggling I looked like a wounded wde
beast in those nature shows and Dave
came alongside as I was cramping up and
walk got me through but setting a time
setting a goal I'm not sure his feet
touched the ground The Last Mile I think
we carried you I did oh no I actually
ran but it was it was all guts and there
was no Glory by the way ever none
oh bless his heart this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey folks Dr John deloney here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad movie
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with a daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's 3 months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember howow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 990 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the Ramy show question of
the day is sponsored by neighborly your
hub for Home Services take your home's
efficiency and style to the next level
with convenient solutions from shelf
Genie window Genie and Glass Doctor
download the neighborly app now to find
and schedule home service professionals
near you today's question comes from
Jeffrey in Connecticut what are some
good careers to trans transition from
being a teacher I'm in my third year
teaching and I would quit tomorrow if I
could I absolutely adore my students
with the district I work for is making
life unbearable I thought about
transitioning in a few years but at this
point I'm at my Breaking Point well
first let me let me say sorry Jeffrey I
I hear from teachers uh on my show the
can show all the time I see it on social
media the environment in which our
Public School teachers are having to
teach is absolutely uh awful in many
cases and it is making good men and
women like you want to leave a very
honorable profession so to ideate here
what we want to do is is we want to
realize that the reason you want to
leave is because you're doing this right
thing this thing you love in the wrong
place so if you can't stay in actual
teaching maybe in a private school
environment or maybe in a college
environment that might be slightly more
uh advantageous to you as far as
students wanting to be there then I
would be looking at what you do as a
teacher what you're good at that's the
instructing the planning the
communicating the
encouraging and and then write down what
you love most about those roles and what
you're going to do is in this little
exercise is create a job description
that's written down and you can see it
and now when you're out there looking
for roles you can begin to match up what
you love about teaching what you're good
at in teaching and you begin to see that
you could go into corporate training you
could go into HR work uh you could go
into management and Leadership there
really is no No Limit if you understand
what you're good at as a teacher and
what you enjoy doing as a teacher and
that becomes the job description and I
can tell you this the private sector uh
is very welcoming to former teachers
because you bring such a great mix of
talent and experience to the table and
you care about people that's what
teaching is about instructing
influencing so that someone can
transform and grow and so that's what I
would be looking for and if you take the
education lens off and just look at what
you do I think you're going to find a
lot of
opportunities yeah and I would add uh
while you're working towards finding
what your work life looks like your
volunteer life could be with the youth
group at the
church and teaching a Sunday school
class to teenagers teaching lessons at
summer camp to
teenagers um and and that might not
necessarily be how you earn your living
but it might be an outlet for your gift
as well um in my 20s I hung out with
teenagers all the time yeah um as a
matter of fact I went to funeral of one
of my friends this weekend that was one
of the youth leaders um back then and a
lot of the kids that were there that are
now of course not kids uh they're
they're have children of their own now
and that kind of thing they're older
than my kids cuz they were in those days
and but to seeing that whole group of
teens that were that we taught back then
and the impact that it's had on their
lives hopefully positively but yeah
that's uh there there's a lot of ways to
use your giftings in this but teaching
is um for some reason we have declared
that teaching is only occurs in the
classroom and teaching occurs a lot of
different places um I'm positive that
one of my spiritual gifts is teaching
I'm a teacher I teach you guys every day
here I teach you with books I teach you
in curriculum I teach you uh on this
show um but convincing you of a new idea
teaching you something you didn't know
before and so that that's all I am is
just another a glorified teacher and so
uh it's one of the reasons I get so
fired up is if somebody's not learning
right that's right that's right so yeah
you got a lot of opportunity out there
Jeffrey a lot of things you can go to
where you don't have to pull put up with
the U garbage being shoveled by your
District Jane is in Canada hi Jane
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hello I'm so thrilled to be on your
show thank you for having me how are you
guys better than I deserve how can we
help okay I have a rather complicated um
slash sad but uh trying to make the most
most of my
situation um situation going going on so
my husband passed away in August oh no
what happened
um that's a complication he died of
alcoholism he died of therosis I'm sorry
um so thank you he he was the bread
winner he at one point made a lot of
money and we had a beautiful renovated
house in Toronto which we which I have
sold because I couldn't afford to keep
it um so I am left with a chunk of money
um I've got two small kids seven and 12
so I'm a single parent I'm a classical
pianist um so obviously I don't make a
ton of money but you know I'm okay but
so I've got about $1.5
million and my question is do I put I
live in Toronto downtown where I would
really like to stay and I I know that
you know I don't have to stay here but
my kids I'm trying to minimize their
disruption and also my work is downtown
so for me to buy a house would be about
1.3 and I could do it in cash but I also
know that you're not a fan of my pretty
much all of my net worth being in a
house so do you think that I should I'm
a fan of you not having a house payment
right now and Toronto is an excellent
real estate market so I'm okay with that
I'm probably going to try to change my
budget on this house from you know 1.3
to one or something like that let's try
to free up a little bit more of this
money
and downsize the kids the disruption to
the kids is going to be a lot more
severe if their mom is stressed out
because she gets herself in a financial
pinch than based on where they live so
I'm a lot more concerned with you
building a sustainable life
mathematically than I am where you live
as far as the children's disruption goes
they don't know they don't know all
they're going to know is what you tell
them and believe me you're going tell
them a lot without telling them a thing
if you get financially stressed so um
let let's get down on that budget and
free up some more of that money and then
also can your career sustain you guys at
that
point well here's the complication is so
I'm renting right now and I know that
I've been watching you guys religiously
for the last sort of six months that
you're in support of me renting
shortterm M um in time of stress and
transition but not long term right but I
don't have my piano with me where I'm
making money is I'm at two different
conservatories downtown Toronto so I
could make more money having my piano
which is in storage because I moved from
a rather large house to a two-bedroom
apartment just to get my bearings yeah
that's fine and so when you get a house
you get a piano and then you can make
money giving lessons I'm guessing or
what yes that's Wonder lessons and doing
it
online my guess with an online lesson
program and some inhouse lessons that
you might make more doing that than you
are um playing in the local
Orchestra am I right oh absolutely yeah
Y no I mean I have good potential to
make quite a good living yeah okay let's
set that let's set up that small
business idea as a part of this home
purchase but still it does not have to
be there's no requirement that is 1.3
that's just where you've landed so far
so the further down you land on that the
better this ideaa
is and the more you're not going to like
it but that's still the direction I
would go I'd try to get down as cheap as
I can on the house and still meet these
different needs the location the uh size
for the piano that makes a lot of sense
I think she can do really well with that
I think so too and and because of her
cred you know she she's not just someone
who has a degree she knows people too
and so I would really encourage you Jane
to maximize the relationship that you
have because of what you currently do
and they begin to spread the word for
you it's really really credible I think
you have more business than you'll know
what to do with and I think I would be
charging premium taking your time as you
as you're moving into this new season of
life we're really excited for you uh
because this is a great opportunity for
you to reset and rebuild yep it's good
stuff if we can help further you call us
anytime I'm so sorry for your loss
thanks for calling
in Ken Coleman that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the book
[Music]
[Applause]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store
[Music]
today live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the Ramsey show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one bestselling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
as we talk about your career your job
your life your money it's all right here
the phone number Isle 8825
5225 Anna or Anna is with us in Los
Angeles Hi how how are you hello um how
are you I'm doing great good how can we
help um so I've been working for some
time now and um I I thought I I did a
okay job for Building up my personal
wealth but um I also like um to hear uh
your opinion about how I'm doing this
far okay how are you doing tell me about
it yeah so um I've been in the real
estate business um for many years um
personally I have four rental properties
and the yearly income is about 50,000
given or more or less um the total
Mortgage Balance I have about is a a
million um and one thing um I don't know
what what I was thinking but I did take
out a home equity line um the purpose of
purchasing other properties um so so far
I've been paying it off the highest it
was close to
600,000 but based on my calculation
that's back in 2019 and I should be able
to pay that off completely off um by
next year um middle of next year and
then you'll still have then you'll still
have a million dollars out on the
rentals correct yes okay and you make
what a year uh that's the wild card so
I'm in real estate so that's old you
make last year to say last year is about
200 okay all right that's probably your
average year right yes okay yeah all
right good for you and so what's your
plan just stay in that the rest of your
life I mean what's your
plan so sounds like it because it sounds
like you keep buying rentals with more
debt yeah and and that's my question
although I have these rental properties
but I I I always feel
I have this piece of rock um in inside
of me it's I feel very very heavy yep so
it's a million dollar
Rock it's right there in your stomach
yeah yeah so should I get rid of some of
the properties so to get rid of this
feeling um I'm not sure what to do I
would develop a game plan to have them
all paid off within a certain period of
time there's nothing panicked here cuz
there's no desperate situation
but what you're experiencing is you
finally are measuring
risk and most of us I grew up in the
real estate business on so I you know I
understand when you get in the real
estate business one of the things they
do is they take a hammer and they break
your risk
meter we don't even know how to measure
risk once we're in that business CU we
just buy crap I mean it's just like we
go get a getting a mortgage to buy an
investment property is like that's the
only way to do it in our minds you can't
do it you can't do it otherwise we just
people in the real estate business
really believe that it's just not true
true but we believe it to be true so um
but what you're you're starting to feel
the weight of the risk that you've taken
on that no one in your world talks about
but you're starting to feel it and
that's what how you ended up talking to
us so yeah what are these properties
worth total you owe a million on them
what are they words total total I would
say about five million good for you okay
so that's a great Equity position I mean
obviously you're in a 20% loan to value
ratio which is phenomenal that that's
not a big risk position but there is a
million dollars worth of problems there
so what I would do is say I'm going to
pay off that million with my income and
with the sale strategically of one or a
couple of these properties over the next
5 years okay and it might be you can
just sell one of them and be clear and
clear the rest of them and that'd be
pretty cool and then from there you pay
cash for all of your additions to your
portfolio you don't use home equity
loans ever again you don't borrow again
to do that because you've got great cash
flow when you have no mortgages and that
that's going to be the way to go yeah
she's going to be in a really great
position out there so now I'm curious
Dave so you wouldn't sell why not sell
one of the houses and knock it out that
way yeah that's what I'm saying I'd pick
out one of those proper all right all
right and and or the income but I mean
if it takes you two years to do this and
of a month right that's okay there's
nothing on fire but you do want to aim
at having a debt-free
portfolio and aim at and stick with the
promise to yourself that any additions
to the portfolio we're doing with cash
yeah as soon as we get first and
foremost get to debt-free
then when we add something later we're
going to do that with um you know
without borrowing money to do that and
folks I understand that the get-rich
quick real estate world and borrow all
you can on real estate out there is out
there it's always been out there and I
understand it's real hot again that tick
teac has made it really a big thing
again and uh you guys get on there and
there's all these goobers on there that
have no life history that you know
they're 14 years old and they're I'm
buying houses and I got this figured
it's a bunch of crap you don't I
mean when I was 22 years old out of
college I started buying houses nothing
down
I bought $4 million worth I had a $1
million net worth by the time I was 24
years old I made
$250,000 cash taxable income doing flips
in
1984 that's $20,000 a month in
1984 you want to put that in today's
dollars that's a half million dollars a
year okay now I don't know what
neighborhood you grew up in but the
neighborhood I grew up in we called that
Rich it was fun I was having a blast
until I found out about risk and the
banks called our notes and we spent the
next two and a half years of our life
losing everything we owned we were sued
we were foreclosed on and with a brand
new baby a toddler and a marriage
Hanging On by a thread cuz my poor wife
thought she had Mar married sir Galahad
turns out it was
goober and there we were bankrupt and at
28 years old I got the opportunity to
start completely over because I followed
the exact same crap you people are
seeing on Instagram and Tik Tok and
you're all walking around acting like
you're smart you're not you're straight
up freaking stupid quit doing it I
walked it and don't tell me you know
more listen a man with an experience is
not at the mercy of a man with an
opinion this is ridiculous you guys I've
walked the exact path that some of you
are signing up for right now now not her
she's got a different situation she's
moving away from the debt she's calling
about that but this zero down nothing
down I'm going to get rich in real
estate is absolute bull crap broke
people shouldn't buy real estate it
makes them broker that's why they call
them
Brokers this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
yeah
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our Ramy show annual
listener survey is now live we want to
know your favorite parts of the show
what you like what you don't like what
you want to hear more about uh whatever
it is we want to hear from you two ways
to participate you can text survey to 33
789 or you can go to ramseys
solutions.com
survey and fill out the survey either
way if you sign up you're going to be
entered to win a
$500 gift card ter is with us in
Pennsylvania hi Taran welcome to the
ramsy
show hi hi um so I recently got my b or
my Master's Degree I got it last year um
I'm in the field of education and a
position had opened up at my current job
um that's in my area of expertise so I
had applied for it I interviewed and I
found out that they want me for the job
however um they had to clear with my b
my supervisor supervisor before I was
allowed to transfer um and my supervisor
waited um about a week before answering
and said that I could go but not for
over three months um and so I'm kind of
torn because I you know I'm thankful
that he said yes I could transfer um but
it's also just seems like an excessive
time to keep me um and so re
is um I'm in I teach special ed so it's
kind of hard to find people um so I
assume that's it um but you know I mean
the end of January that's seems like
just a long time to hold
someone so I guess I'm just it does
wondering it's not a long time three
months good no how old are you
Taran uh I'm 27 yeah so I was 27 long
time ago and a long yeah I knew that was
coming but and and the reason I said
that Terry is because this is not a
judgment on you three months is a really
long time for 27 year old but for old
guys like us I'm here to tell you that
three months is not a long time and they
really are probably in a crunch but
instead of children you take care of
have to have someone to take care of
them if you're leaving right they have
to line that up and those people are
hard to find is that not
true it is true we have a lot of new
people coming um but I guess with that
um yeah you were getting to a question
that they're kind of debating whether or
not they are going to go with me or go
with someone else because of the time
frame um they're kind of like not in a
hurry but they would like to get someone
to fill the position shortly so okay so
all within the same district though
right
yeah yeah it's at a cyber school so it's
all within the same company yeah so they
should be able to go one part of the
company is willing to release some of
their talent to go to the other part of
the company as soon as they're able to
do a back fill so we will wait until the
back fill comes in we do that inside of
Ramsey all the time but if we want to if
you want to move inside of here we don't
move you until we have your workload
covered M but we don't also don't fill
the position out from under you we'll
say you can go over there as quick as we
get somebody hired to take what you're
doing you know what I'm saying and if
you can get that Assurance then you
shouldn't have any issue with this
agreed yes yes if I if I know they're
willing to wait I guess that's one thing
no I mean you're hired you're hired for
the new position as soon as your
backfill comes
in if you can get that Pro if you can
get that promise three months is
reasonable yeah so you're not so what
are you wrestling
with if she can't get that promise
should she stay so yeah and I guess
because we're also um like my husband
and I were in baby step to we're hoping
to start homeschooling our sons so I'm
like oh you know if I if I don't get
this position because it really is my
dream job if they're not willing to wait
um I would like to leave the company um
because I just don't and I don't know if
that's a crazy idea too but if I don't
get that job well it's not about it's
not about crazy it's about you and your
husband talking about if that's a viable
option with you being in baby step two
that's a pretty big hit you're just
going to quit and I I just wouldn't I
wouldn't if it were me I'd say wait a
second I want to try to maneuver this
thing I I think you've got to sit down
with the the uh the new opportunity and
say hey I need to know I know that my
supervisor has cleared this but with a
three-month wait are you guys willing to
do what Dave said and say all right
we're signing on the bottom line it's
your position and quick as quick as we
can get a Back Field I'll be over there
because that's reasonable it is
reasonable it's also reasonable for the
people moving that you're moving to to
wait and not damage their own
company
MH but I wouldn't quit how big of a hit
would it be if you go home and and and
homeschool and you're not making money
how
much yeah I mean it would be I mean
before tax like
$65,000 I would not recommend that I
would not recommend that they haven't
done anything wrong yeah there's not an
Ethics breakdown here and they're not a
horrible people or a horrible company uh
they do need to give you some clarity I
don't disagree with you on that I'd get
I'd like for them to give you the lock
down on the position but but I if they
won't give you that Clarity they still
haven't done anything wrong they're
sloppy is all and if you want to work
somewhere else that's fine um but you
might jump from there to a place that's
totally toxic you know that could happen
real easy yeah happens because this is
not what you're describing is not
unreasonable or toxic in any stretch of
the imagination now if they lie to you
cheat you hold you back artificially
with no solid reason we're just screwing
around with you because we just can
that's toxic but this is saying hey we
got to fill this position these little
kids need a teacher and if Taran steps
out we got a big hole over here these
children are not going to be taken care
of that's very reasonable yeah as a
matter of fact it's
responsible um it's not saying I'm going
to politically hold you back it's saying
hey yeah you can go as soon as we get
your work covered and then the other
play The Other Side the place you be
going needs to give you the clarity and
say all right the position jurors as
soon as they can get the back fill over
at the other place we we'll we'll bring
you over but and we're you know we we
understand the time Horizon might be as
much as 3 months we've done that here
Ken and sometimes it's even been more
than 3 months that's right I mean that's
the reality of workflow and you have to
understand that you have to be patient I
know it's hard my goodness it's it's
hard to be patient at 37 47 or 57 uh
certainly 27 but we've got to keep our
eye on the big picture and here's the
other thing I just want to mention very
briefly
because I if we see an opportunity like
this and it looks like it's right there
but then there's a hurdle there's
reality sets in and and if for some
reason she doesn't get this we shouldn't
hang up hang up the cleats we shouldn't
just say we're done we're out we're
we're not going to play anymore uh
because take my toys and go home yeah
because it it represents the dream job
but it's not the only dream job that's
the key the dream job is already a bit
of a unicor corn for a lot of people
that's why I've actually stopped using
the phrase a lot because I think for
some people they think well it's the
playing in the NFL or something
something that's not realistic it's not
the dream job feels like a dream because
you're spending most of your day using
what you do best to do something you
really enjoy to produce results that you
care deeply about that is really a dream
for most people because the alternative
to that is a nightmare if you do it too
long and so don't get hung up on that
was the dream job that can really
devastate you and knock a lot of people
off that path and and I would really
caution all of our audience on this to
say okay it looks it smells it feels
like it but if it's not it that's okay
don't think no think not yet not here
and keep moving forward and that's what
I'd want her attitude to be if this
doesn't work out yeah um by the way
dream job is what you said it's doing
things you love with the gifts you have
that's right to accomplish something and
see traction yes in something you're
passionate and care about that's right
you know
I've got the dream job that doesn't mean
that last week didn't suck right right
you have some of those days last week
kind of sucked you know and it was a
long week and I'm really thankful I
don't have last week anymore I'm glad
it's gone glad I'm glad I've gotten next
week instead but but this idea that you
know every you know like you're not
going to run
into conflict in your dream job of
course you're going to run into conflict
in your dream job you're not going to
run into uh crappy people while you're
doing your dreams oh yes you can be
assured that if you run into people
you're going to run into some crappy
ones just count on it you know I mean
you can you none of this is going to get
easy just because it's your dream job
like you don't it's all rainbows and
Skittles or something it's just that
that's just crap it doesn't work that
way boys and girls this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
I
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Andrew
and Emily are with us hey guys how are
you hey good how are you better than I
deserve where do you guys live
Weatherford Texas all right welcome to
Nashville how much debt have you paid
off so we paid off 55,000 good for you
and how long did this Take 6 months 6
months and your range of income come
during that time we started at 1:10 and
finished at 1:30 cool what do youall do
for a living I'm a financial adviser mhm
and I work as a pediatric nurse very
good good for you great careers how long
y'all been married one year okay so
right after marriage you look up and you
got 55,000 what kind of debt two cars
and student loans all right and you
start off with a burden here and you say
all right we're clearing this and we're
clearing it fast tell me the story what
happened how'd you get turned on to us
so I've known about all for a while and
um we had been talking about this for
kind of what we wanted to do and I
started reading The Total Money Makeover
and was It was kind of firing me up and
then uh we celebrated her birthday on
December 14th and I pretty much came
home and was like let's pay off the car
and after that it was like what else can
we pay off what can we switch around in
our budget to make it work for us and I
think that's kind of where it all
started for US ah so you got the
financial gas state
I think I'm just impatient very
impatient good I like it got we're gonna
actually do this stuff you're reading
about yeah good very cool I got to know
Dave was the new The Newlywed groom did
you figure out I should probably make
her happy with this or did you push back
a little bit or were you all in what was
going on when she came home with this
idea well it's pretty hard to once she
has her mind set to something it's
pretty hard to get her off and so we had
been talking about like hey what are we
going to do with this and then she said
hey I want to pay off my car and then
right after that I said hey I've got a
truck a nice Chevy Silverado I think I
think we probably should sell it and
that can knock off a lot and you sold
your truck we sold dream truck Texas
Texas oh wow that's not that's not that
that's real yes sir sold it to buy a car
too yeah and people I bet you had people
saying you have lost your mind yes sir
very much so yeah
wow how much was the truck it was the
balance when we sold it was about 27,000
so was half of this debt yes sir and
then um we rolled that into and then the
Ultimo was what we bought and we we did
not pay for it fully we ended up that
became a new part and so uh the next
thing was her student loans and then the
car was last and so we took it from
Total Money Makeover try to get fun
creative so we created a whiteboard it
had the total amount how much we had
paid and then um every time we paid
something off we would play the song
Jump Around from House of Pain yes and
it's one of Dave's favorite
songs yeah we would just like blast it
through the house and like just Just
Dance like just yeah why not got to
knock out another one I love it dance
party I love it that's fun good job you
guys thank you okay so you're married a
year and you're debt free how's it feel
pretty good pretty good you sold the
truck yes sir was it worth it it was
worth it 100% buy the truck later you'll
get another tree right that's what I
exactly you're going to get another one
later and another one and another one
and another one yes sir it's not like
you're only going to own one truck in
your life I mean come on wow that's
awesome guys way to go all right young
married couples out there listening
they're going how did they do that well
they sold the truck as part of it how
they pay off $55 in debt what do you
tell them the secret to getting out of
debt is um I would say accountability
and just staying to it even though
you're like man I'm losing my truck and
may not be able to do all the things
that other married couples are going to
do just sticking with it now you can now
you can do anything right yes sir yeah
I'm curious you guys you're newly wed
this is exciting so what are you
dreaming about now that you're debt free
like how what's the mindset looking
forward the rest of your life we're on
baby step 3A right now okay and then
maybe step 3B would be next so we uh the
next step is definitely to buy a house
okay um and so that's where we're
looking for short short term and then
longterm whatever the Lord has in store
for us we don't really know yeah and and
how old are you
too I love it good wow you're in such
good shape you're going to be you're
going to be so stinking Rich it's
unbelievable the math on things when
you're 24 guys it's just oh it's awesome
yeah I got to ask you guys this what's
your what are you aiming for for that
first time home what price
range oh at this rate we have a really
tiny um rent home which is perfect but
at this I think we can make any home a
home so I good for you meaning you're
not going to get locked into something
over your skis there you guys are going
to be smart about this yes sir that's
great love that yeah wow that's the big
draw for a lot of young couples they
want to get that really nice house like
Mom and Dad had grown up they're like no
no no you know I was listening to a guy
the other day and he said the secret to
Building Wealth is marrying well mhm I
mean you could marry a princess who
demands an Instagram house yes or you
can marry Emily who says I can make a
home anywhere yeah I thought the same
thing Dave that's that's that's a
freaking home run that's awesome by the
way Andrew I mean I'm sure a lot of
people have told you you clearly outm
married yourself and that's a good thing
that's a compliment you know we're glad
she has poor judgment and and so that's
you have done well sir no question about
it that's what I say about my wife
that's not personal yes sir it's very
true well done very well done I'm proud
of y'all thank you and who was cheering
you on out there well we had a lot of
people supporting us um it was kind of
it was a good amount of people I mean
family friends um it was always
interesting when we would tell people
what we were doing uh just the reactions
were varied most people knew about y'all
some people didn't but they were like
wow good for y'all um and so it was just
a good community of supporters yeah they
walk away Shake in their head he sold
his truck he sold his truck there was a
lot of that there a lot of that he sold
his truck oh my God as if you're never
going to get another truck I mean you're
going to be so rich you can have five
trucks I mean who cares you know
unbelievable not really Emily he won't
do that no actually they'll be wealthy
enough they can get five trucks it won't
matter honestly I mean I mean you want
me the math is like 4050 million bucks I
mean it's just like crazy that's true
yeah way to go y'all way to go we're
proud of you I can tell you that and we
know that the sacrifice you made is
temporary although painful and you got
there and now you get to go anywhere you
want to go talk about buying a house
talk about the next steps very very cool
stuff we've got the live and give box
for you it's got the baby steps
millionaires book in it for sure you'll
be in one of those and uh The Total
Money Makeover book to give away to one
of your friends that this is how I did
this I just did this right here and the
Financial Peace University membership as
well enjoy them give them whatever you
need to do that's what they're they
there our gift to you guys to say uh
congratulations and thanks for coming to
Nashville to do your debt-free scream
all the way from Fort Worth Texas Andrew
and Emily wow
55,000 paid off in six months making 110
to 130 count it down let's hear a
debt-free
scream right quick go rangers three 2
one we're dead free
yeah
[Applause]
w
wow hey that's a power couple right
there yep 24 power couple looking for a
place to happen is't that true it's
extraordinary to see young couples
committing early on first 6 months of
their marriage they're like okay we're
getting after it most powerful wealth
building tool that allows you to get out
of debt and build wealth and be
unreasonably generous is contentment
contentment allows you to sell your
truck when everyone thinks you're crazy
contentment says I can make a home in
anything these are the these are the
verbs the words that people use when
they're functioning in contentment
godliness with contentment is great gain
yeah and that's definitely what they're
walking in and you know that's a
decision it's a decision where I place
my values am I defined by where I live
what I drive if I'm not then suddenly
I'm what's called content I can get nice
things and I can not get nice things but
either one's fine and and it works works
out either way and that's that's the
beauty of where they are and the irony
is it's the key that's going to make
them extremely wealthy yeah and put them
in a position to be outrageously
generous and help people everywhere
around them they're going to be they're
an amazing couple just amazing and
congrats parents I'm sure they're
watching and listening both
sides dad both of you y all crushed it
that's a great great couple yeah just
slam dunk this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the Day Psalms
1282 you will eat the fruit of your
labor blessings and prosperity will be
yours Claude McDonald said if hard work
is the key to success most people would
rather pick the
lock and that's the
truth Katie is with us in Concord New
Hampshire hi Katie welcome to the ramsy
show hi oh God this is actually
happening okay breathe Katie it's gonna
be
good holy
moly what's up how can we help
overwhelmed with gratitude this is crazy
okay um first I need to thank you for um
everything thank you how can we
help um
so okay Dave you have to promise not to
yell at
me um my boyfriend and I have combined
it all of our debt and our bank accounts
and we are um gelle intense on um our
debt um we have about uh $89,000 left um
we have smashed out all the credit cards
there's no more credit card debt which
is very freeing um so now we're working
on student loan and Auto Loan um but my
question is um my my family and I have
recently joined a church that um you
know my children and I were baptized in
and
um every month you know uh we have our
budget meeting you know and um I'm the
planner and he gets to change my plan
which I don't really like very much but
um my question is every month after
month after month um the church column
um is a bunch of zeros because um I feel
like I don't really have anything to
give
um and I just I want to be able to give
um the 10% of her income is when are you
getting
married ask
him um I've actually had this
conversation with him um I've actually
been married twice before um so in his
dating we've been dating for over a year
okay if you're if you're willing to
completely combine your finances you
should never do that unless you're
married and then you should do it
immediately but this is very dangerous
for you very
vulnerable yeah yeah so um if either
take your finances back aart or get
married what was his response when you
brought it up to
him marriage um so we we talk about it
we we want to get married his thing is
like he wants to be able to provide
picture perfect for me um sorry that's
not an option yeah there's no such thing
I got a hunch here real quick Katie what
does what does he make income wise and
what do you make separate
those um okay so I make um one two three
like 4,000 in a month okay give or take
okay what does he and he makes
about uh 55 okay 100 roughly
okay and I actually have more debt than
he does okay well number one let's just
back up back the bus up here either get
married in the next 30 days or separate
your finances yeah this is very
dangerous for you I'm scared for you
okay you should not be paying his debt
he should not be paying your debt when
you're not married you are going to get
it's going to put a strain on the
relationship something's going to blow
up and one of you is going to get left
in an unfair disadvantage due to this
broken system that you should not be
using I'm not yelling at you I just want
good for you I love you I want you to
win then the then once you've made the
decision to either separate your
finances or combine them because you're
getting married immediately not next
year okay um then I mean this is not
something you need to plan for two years
paint or get off the ladder and then um
then then once you decide all that then
we can come to your question how do we
put you've just started attending church
you how do you put Church in the budget
well you don't put Church in the budget
you put God in generosity in the budget
and for those of us that are Evangelical
Christians the first stage
of Baseline generosity is a tenth of our
income going to the local church but
that is an act of
worship that's an act of of not trying
to buy God's favor he he doesn't need
your money he says to do this because he
wants to turn you into a generous person
because generous people are much better
children and you and I are better
children of God when we are generous and
so so he's trying to turn us into that
and that's what the tithe was
established for it's not established as
a rule it's not established as a shaming
mechanism by religious zealots it's
established as a method of teaching us
the power of generosity when it's a
regular rhythm in our lives and so were
I you I would live on 90% of my income
and be giving a tenth of my income to my
local church if I'm a person of Faith
that's not a condemnation but it's what
I have done for 40 years and it's worked
really really well for me and there's no
guarantee you're not going to have bad
times there's no guarantee of anything
it's just an act of generosity and it's
teaching us the rhythm of generosity a
baseline start and I was in a church
when I was going bankrupt Katie in my
20s as a baby Christian and um there
were people there that would say things
like well you know God protects you if
you tith then I went uh missed that part
went
bankrupt I missed that well and then I
had one old blue-haired lady say well
you just didn't have enough faith and I
said honey I didn't have anything left
but Faith they took everything else MH
so I mean come on yeah so uh broken
Doctrine broken
theology uh but and so you can get
twisted up in all that toxic garbage or
you can just say hey I'm going to live
life with an open hand and I'm going to
be a generous person
because generous people smile more
generous people are less often depressed
generous people are better at
relationships because who wants to be in
a relationship with a selfish person no
one right and so the act of generosity
is a becomes a character quality and it
changes your whole life and so yeah I'm
going to put that at the top of my list
of things to do absolutely but not as a
legalism rule yeah absolutely right that
is really scary Doctrine and it's what
drives a lot of people people away from
the faith if you think you got to give
God money to get something good from him
that is that is a recipe for frustration
and Desperation yeah as if he needs his
your permission to bless you right you
know and and as if his Blessing is
dependent upon you giving him a nickel
good gracious as he if he wanted your
money he'd take it to a big greasy spot
where you were sitting I mean he's God I
mean come on you going need your money
that's not the point the point and and
so don't be shamed by it Katie and don't
be going because I heard the guilt oh
every month I feel bad cuz there's
nothing in the church column well I mean
put something in there but don't do it
out of Shame do it out of hey I want to
learn a different way of living that
includes
generosity and it includes a
smile and it includes being married to
this guy you fallen in love with and
combining your whole life not just your
money and uh let's do the whole deal
let's go game on but don't pay someone's
debts ever and don't let someone pay
your debts that you're not married to
you're going to get yourself in a pinch
been doing this a long time and I never
see good of it it ends as delone says
all the time this ends in
Ash o that's a pretty harsh statement
but it does it just the thing thing
Burns to the ground so I I want you to
win kiddo we love you and I'm happy that
you're and your family are in a good
church and it sounds like you're
starting your journey there um and or
resetting your journey there that's
awesome any of that I'm cheering you on
Ken's cheering you on we want you to win
um and um no we're not yelling at you
that's not what we do um we we yell at
Concepts not people but um yeah don't
you know those of you that are shacking
up and aren't getting married you can do
that if you want to do it I won't be mad
at you I'm not going to yell at you um
but don't combine your money don't
combine your money cuz you're going to
get burned don't buy a house for
somebody you're not married to you're
going to get burned I get it all the
time in here it's all the time and you
just setting yourself up you make dumb
decisions like that you get yourself
burned we don't want that for you that
puts us hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the ramsy baby
steps go to Ramsey solutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's Ramy solutions.com and
click get
[Music]
started